I think this is one of the one of the
problems we have is we over value skill
and undervalue humanity and undervalue
trustworthiness and undervalue loyalty
and undervalue empathy and patience and
all of these very human skills that we
want in good parents and good teachers
and good leaders and as your profession
adapts to a new world where automation
is let's use a bold term threatening the
livelihoods of many people and probably
the existence of many firms the you
can't double down on skills because
that's the stuff that's gonna get
automated you've got to double down on
leadership stuff uu we'd be the biggest
hypocrites in the world if we stand on
this stage and tell everybody it's all
about the relationship but then don't
teach anybody how to build relationships
just continue to pump skills into them
then you're then you're literally I I
generally believe that bankruptcy
bankruptcy very often as an act of
suicide you know that that you people
who you know when organizations go
bankrupt both internal or external
commentators will say disruption its
disruption the mark it's technology has
disrupted our that's a defensive
response which is we can see what's
gonna happen like this is not difficult
the Kodak is a prime Kodak is a great
example Kodak invented the digital
camera right in 1975 suppressed the
technology for fear that would
cannibalize film sales predicted that 10
years later this digital thing would
happen and over the course of those 10
years they did nothing and they made
billions and billions of dollars
licensing the technologies to other
firms from their patents the patents ran
out and five years later they were
bankrupt that's an act of suicide even
though superficially they thought they
were doing well because they were
pulling in billions of dollars in the
balance sure looked amazing but though
company was fundamentally extremely weak
organizations like professions like
yours that historically would say you're
doing great because look at the numbers
you're making money hand over fist and
it's growing every year the new
opportunity is not only to recognize
that the foundations are fundamentally
weak but to actually have the skill set
to knock on the door
I know you're making a ton of money but
you're not doing well well in actuality
there's a lesson there in the profession
because the profession is doing well and
we have to challenge ourselves along
that correct that's that same that same
process making money is no indication of
health
[Music]